come on bro
what's going on with you man
Josh
an investigation is now underway after a
man died in police custody in Texas
what would you like us to do
some hospitals
you're ready to go to the hospital yeah
[Music]
on June 21st Dallas police officers were
investigating a murder when they ran
into 39 year old Xavier Franklin during
a traffic stop hey man do you go to
Texas I do your Mississippi
okay cool what's your last name Frank
I'm sorry Frank last name Franklin hey
there's Franklin okay
your first name brother
huh your first name exactly XC
X
sure
uh yeah Franklin was later taken into
custody because of several outstanding
warrants if you step up for me brother
step up for me real quick let's go put
your handcuffs you're just attained
right now no big deal
you got any weapons
[Applause]
body camera video shows official search
Franklin and put him in the back seat of
a squad car
Franklin is then taken to the police
station to be interviewed
all right we'll get those coats off you
once we get in there go ahead
officials tell Franklin he will soon
speak with a detective as he's placed
into an interview room
just to make sure
after he's interviewed security cameras
capture Franklin getting sick
Franklin continues to throw up for about
10 minutes during this time officials
bring in paper towels in a trash can
they're a little squishy okay
[Music]
hey let me know if you need more tissue
but they are on their way okay Franklin
then discloses he's throwing up blood
everything okay
I'm gonna take your hat real quick okay
you okay no what's wrong I just thought
I'd love it
from what huh from what uh overall I
just have a whip now I'm gonna recover
alcohol okay all right they gotta I
think they got a ambulance coming okay
[Music]
minutes later EMS arrives
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
tells First Responders he would like to
be taken to the hospital what would you
like us to do for you today
[Music]
he's then seen struggling as he walks
out of the room ready
foreign
at about nine o'clock that evening
Franklin died at the hospital an autopsy
is set to be performed on Friday
meanwhile the incident is still under
investigation reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie